il y a quasiment un an le 5 octobre 2021
la commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église remettaient son
rapport pointant du doigt les
agissements criminels de certains
membres de la communauté catholique une
onde de choc qui a trouvé un écho
particulier en Touraine avec la création
du collectif voit libéré qui regroupe
d'anciens Petits Chanteurs de Touraine
ses enfants devenus adultes accusent un
prêtre touranjo d'agression sexuelle et
de viol alors aujourd'hui où on est
cette affaire éléments de réponse avec
Audrey Champigny
il n'était que des enfants à l'époque de
petits choristes obéissant aux ordres de
leur supérieur un homme d’église qu'ils
accusent d'avoir abusé d'eux depuis un
an le collectif voie libéré tente de
retrouver ses enfants pour qu'ils
puissent enfin parler on en a trouvé en
recherchant plusieurs chanteurs de toute
époque puisque on rappelle que la
monnaie country les Petits Chanteurs a
duré entre les années 60 et les années
90 2000 donc c'était très large donc on
a réussi donc à contacter près de 200
chanteurs ils semblerait qu'il y en a à
peu près 1000 et dans ces chanteurs là
il y a eu Manor malheureusement des gens
qui ont été abusés donc pour l'instant
on dénombre 9 plaintes qui ont été
déposées officiellement en gendarmerie
ces plantes et ses témoignages visent un
homme l'abbé Bernard tartue qui a dirigé
pendant 50 ans la chorale des Petits
Chanteurs de Touraine
malgré la prescription de certains faits
présumés les victimes demandent
aujourd'hui réparations
[Musique]
je pense que si il veut retrouver lui
aussi la paix le mieux c'est de
contacter Christophe Gilles Nicolas
Benoît Olivier Frédéric tous ceux qui
qui souffrent tous les jours ça serait
peut-être pas très compliqué avant de
partir de pouvoir au moins fermer cette
parenthèse et puis que tout le monde
soit apaisé
pour beaucoup le souvenir de ces années
de manécanterie restera à jamais
par les abus qu'ils auraient subis
aujourd'hui quand on pose la question à
Christian s'il est toujours croyant
moi j'ai là ça m'a ça c'est quelque
chose qui va sûrement faire du mal à pas
mal mais on a pris tous une
claque le jour où on a découvert que
Gilles avait été abusé par exemple et
qu'on la suit par voie de presse
c'est une des platration c'est une
déflagration tout tout ce qu'on avait
mis dans l'église d'un seul coup se
trouve ébranlé en août une charte a été
signée par la Fédération des maniques
pour protéger les Petits Chanteurs de
son côté l'archevêque de Tours
Monseigneur Jordy s'est engagé auprès du
collectif à travailler pour la
prévention des abus sexuels au sein de
l'Église catholique